LIZ CHENEY, STILL A REPUBLICAN,
IS TALKING ABOUT WHAT MIGHT
HAPPEN IF DONALD TRUMP RUNS
AGAIN IN 2024.
LISTEN TO WHAT SHE SAID.
>> I THINK THAT THE PARTY HAS
EITHER GOT TO COME BACK FROM
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW, WHICH IS
A VERY DANGEROUS AND TOXIC
PLACE.
OR THE PARTY WILL SPLINTER AND
THERE WILL BE A NEW CONSERVATIVE
PARTY THAT RISES.
AND IF DONALD TRUMP IS THE
NOMINEE OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY,
THE PARTY WILL SHATTER AND THERE
WILL BE A CONSERVATIVE PARTY
THAT RISES IN ITS PLACE.
>> TARA THINKS OR HOPES?
>> I THINK SHE HOPES.
I THINK SHE SEES HERSELF AS THE
SPLINTER, AS THE STANDARD BEARER
OF THE NEW ANTI-TRUMP REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
THE PROBLEM IS ARE THERE ENOUGH
PEOPLE BEHIND HER THAT COULD
MAKE THAT HAPPEN?
I THINK SHE'S GOING TO BE AN
INTERESTING DYNAMIC DURING THE
ELECTION IF SHE DOES RUN.
SHE WILL GET ALL THE PRESS.
YOU HAVE A HALF DOZEN CANDIDATES
MADE BY TRUMP AND SHE MIGHT BE
THERE ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL OR
THE DEBATE STAGE, PUMMELLING HIM
AND SHE MAY RISE UP.
I DON'T THINK SHE'LL GET ENOUGH
VOTES TO WIN A PRIMARY.
>> TWO THINGS, ONE IS THE
POSSIBILITY THAT LIZ CHENEY IS
RUNNING TO WARN REPUBLICANS
ABOUT THINGS.
TRUMP IS A LOT OF THINGS BUT NOT
CONSERVATIVE.
AND THE OTHER IS COULD THERE BE
A THIRD PARTY CHALLENGE.
KIND OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING EVAN
McMULLEN MOUNT AGAINST MIKE LEE.
I THINK IT REPRESENTS THE FACT
THAT FOR TRUE OLD SCHOOL
CONSERVATIVES, A RETURN OF
DONALD TRUMP IS THE OPPOSITE OF
EVERYTHING THEY BELIEVE AND
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO SIMPLY
APPEASE HIM AS SOME FOLKS
LOOKING TO GET INTO POWER IN THE
SHORT TERM DO.
>> SHE WASN'T FOCUSED ON THIS.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY RULES IN
THE PRIMARY BENEFITS SOMEONE WHO
CAN GET 30, 40%, WHICH IS DONALD
TRUMP.
SHE MAY BE RIGHT THAT IT WILL
SPLINTER.
BUT IF IT SPLINTERS HE MAY BE
THE BENEFICIARY, WHICH ISN'T
WHAT SHE WAS FOCUSED ON THERE.
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE VICE
CHAIRWOMAN LIZ CHENEY NOT RULING
OUT PUBLIC TESTIMONY IF DONALD
TRUMP COMPLIES WITH THE
COMMITTEE SUBPOENA.
BUT, WHETHER IT'S IN PUBLIC OR
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS, CHENEY
PROMISING THE PANEL WOULDN'T
ALLOW IT TO BECOME A SPECTACLE.
THE COMMITTEE SUBPOENAED TRUMP
ON FRIDAY AND WANTS TESTIMONY
UNDER OATH.
>> WE WON'T ALLOW THE FORMER
PRESIDENT -- HE'S NOT GOING TO
TURN THIS INTO A CIRCUS.
THIS ISN'T GOING TO BE HIS FIRST
DEBATE AGAINST JOE BIDEN AND THE
CIRCUS AND FOOD FIGHT THAT
BECAME.
THIS IS FAR TOO SERIOUS SET OF
ISSUES.
>> GREAT REPORTERS ARE BACK WITH
US, IS THERE ANYONE AT THE TABLE
THAT THINKS DONALD TRUMP WOULD
COMPLY WITH THIS SUBPOENA AND
NOT FIGHT IT FOR MONTHS AND
MONTHS PAST THE LIFE OF THE
COMMITTEE?
>> NO.
HE'S GOING TO DRAG IT OUT.
>> IF PAST IS PROLONGED AND
USUALLY IS WITH DONALD TRUMP,
THIS WAS HIS TACTIC FACING A LIT
KNEE OF LEGAL TROUBLES,
CONGRESSIONAL REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION.
THEY DRAGGED IT OUT.
DRAGGED IT OUT.
THEY PUT IT THROUGH THE COURTS
AND I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED IF
THAT'S THE TACTIC HERE.
>> THIS IDEA THAT THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE A CIRCUS, THE
PROBLEM IS THAT DONALD TRUMP
LEADS THE CIRCUS.
HE BRINGS IT WHEREVER HE GOES.
HE LOVES THE RALLY, THE SHOWMAN.
IF IN SOME, YOU KNOW, WORLD HE
DID TESTIFY.
IT IS GOING TO BE A CIRCUS.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S JUST A FACT.
>> ALSO ASKED TONGUE AND CHEEK
EARLIER WHETHER IF THERE WAS A
GUARANTEE OF A EVENING SHOWING
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD --
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD SAY
YES.
HE DOES LIKE THE ATTENTION AS WE
ALL KNOW, ALL ATTENTION IS GOOD
ATTENTION FOR HIM BUT THE
LIKELIHOOD OF THAT HAPPENING ON
WHAT REPRESENTATIVE CHENEY SAID
IS LOW.
>> I SUSPECT HIS LAWYERS WOULD
SAY NO, NO, NO, ABSOLUTELY NO.
>> CHENEY MADE QUITE CLEAR SHE'S
NOT A FAN OF TRUMP.
SHE THINKS HE'S A THREAT TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND COUNTRY.
SHE MADE CLEAR SHE'S GOING TO
TAKE ISSUE WITH GLENN YOUNGKIN
OUTCOME CAMPAIGNING IN ARIZONA
WITH OTHER ELECTION DENIERS.
LIZ CHENEY SAYS FOR HER THAT'S A
L
TEST.
>> THEY'RE INDEFENSIBLE
DECISIONS.
I SAID I THINK GLENN YOUNGKIN
HAS DONE A GOOD JOB AS GOVERNOR
OF VIRGINIA, BUT NOBODY SHOULD
BE OUT ADVOCATING FOR THE
ELECTION OF PEOPLE WHO WILL NOT
HONOR THE SANCTITY OF OUR
ELECTION PROCESS.
PEOPLE WHO DO THAT ARE IN FACT
PUTTING POLITICS AHEAD OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND AHEAD OF THE
COUNTRY.
>> SHE'S MAKING THAT ARGUMENT 15
DAYS FROM THE MIDTERMS BUT
THAT'S ALSO A FOUNDATION OF THE
ARGUMENT SHE CONTINUE TO MAKE
FROM 2022 TO 2024.
THE QUESTION IS CAN SHE SUCCEED
OR IS SHE A MINORITY IN THE NEW
REPUBLICAN PARTY?
>> SHE'S A MINORITY RIGHT NOW.
SPECIFICALLY ON LIZ CHINA, THE
QUESTION IS WHAT PLATFORM WILL
SHE HAVE NEXT YEAR WHEN SHE'S NO
LONGER A MEMBER OF CONGRESS AND
NO LONGER THE VICE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE?
DOES SHE DECIDE TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT?
DOES SHE FIND ANOTHER WAY TO
KEEP THIS MESSAGE GOING?
SHE IS FOR SURE AT LEAST IN
TERMS OF PEOPLE IN THE PARTY
SPEAKING PUBLICLY AND ADVOCATING
FOR THAT NOT IN THE MAJORITY ON
THAT ISSUE.
>> SO IT'S INTERESTING IN THE
SINCE THAT YOUNGKIN TRIES TO WIN
THE ELECTION AND KEEP FAITH AND
SUPPORT AMONG PEOPLE LIKE KARI
L
LAKE.
LIZ CHENEY SAYS I DON'T WANT ANY
PART OF THAT AND SAYS IF TRUMP
IS THE NOMINEE, IT WILL BE A
FRACTURING AND CONSERVATIVE
MOVEMENT WILL COME TO YOUR POINT
ABOUT WHAT IS HER FUTURE MIGHT
THAT BE IT?
>> I MEAN, I'M NOT QUITE SURE
LIZ CHENEY IS CORRECT THAT IF
TRUMP IS THE NOMINEE THAT THE
PARTY WOULD FRACTURE.
I MEAN, EVEN MITCH McCONNELL WHO
IS ONE OF TRUMP'S BIGGEST
ANTAGONISTS SAID IF HE RUNS IN
2024 HE WOULD SUPPORT HIM.
THAT'S A BIG IF, IF PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS LEADING THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IN 2024 BUT THE PROBLEM
FOR LIZ CHENEY, ALONG WITH WHAT
JEFF SAID IS THAT A LITMUS TEST
FOR HER IS NOT FOR THE REST OF
THE PARTY.
I THINK REPUBLICANS HAVE MADE A
CALCULATIONS THAT EVEN IF THEY
DISMISS THE ELECTION DENIALS
THAT ARE COMING FROM SOME OF THE
CANDIDATES, THAT WINNING FOR
THEM IS A BETTER -- IS BETTER
FOR THEM AT THE END OF THE DAY
SO THEY CAN WIN, PUT IN PLACE
REPUBLICAN POLICIES SO THEY'RE
KIND OF OVERLOOKING THAT HERE,
AND LIZ CHENEY IS A VERY LONELY
VOICE HERE.
>> A LONELY VOICE HOPING THESE
ELECTION DENIEIERS LOSE.
>> I THINK SHE ALSO SAID THAT
HER PRIMARY RACE WAS LIKE A TEST
FOR THE CONSTITUTION OR
WHATEVER, AND SHE DIDN'T WIN
THAT ONE.
SO I THINK THAT THE PROBLEM IS
OVER AND OVER AGAIN LIZ CHENEY'S
PARTY HAS LET HER DOWN AND LEFT
HER BEHIND, AND SO EVEN THOUGH
SHE IS SPEAKING NOW, SHE HAS
THAT PLATFORM, IT DOES NOT SEEM
LIKE IT IS MAKING A DIFFERENCE
AT THIS POINT.
WITH HER OWN PARTY.